yes I'm for each spring a 58 member jury
selects the car of the year this year it
shows the pooja 308 from among some 30
competitors our cart estimate Oscar it
says the 308 certainly looks like a
winner is Alf getting [ __ ] Ramada Inn
Zita tube everything but the name has
changed in the new pujo 308 gone is the
obirrhat design with a huge radiator
grille and paji appearance the grill has
shrunken the headlights are smaller but
more striking the new model
straightforwardness and modesty are
pleasing
well placed styling creases add a dash
of excitement to the body the new Cujo
308 has an elegant dynamic appearance
the implied under ride protection keeps
the rear from being boring so yeah
montes is going to test whether the car
fulfills the promise of its design
yeah that's got tortilla it's obvious he
likes the idea of a screen allowing him
to control everything even the heater
and air conditioner but when the Sun
shines on it from behind he can't see
anything at all he blew it Donna Lizzie
shot it's kind of disappointing to have
to cover the optional glass roof losing
the spacious feeling it provided Anthony
is not really alvida that sooner home
good of course that problem can be
avoided by sticking to the basic 308
with its conventional radio and air
conditioning
that's glad this is a fan of the small
steering wheel which gives the car a
sporty character but travel distance to
shift gears is a bit too long and the
gear shift could be more precise that
would make the car sport here the new
version of the pugio is 140 kilograms
lighter than its predecessor it's
shorter and lower to at 4.25 meters in
length it's a match for the Gulf montes
doesn't like having to set the steering
wheel so low to be able to see the
speedometer and rev counter if you
aren't exceptionally tall setting the
steering wheel higher means your view of
the instruments is no better than in the
conventional arrangement well you look
through the steering wheel to see them
disease of the instrument is definitely
specified by an al Commission on autumn
Foreman Jewish Teslin cash out on top
volunteers are methods in the pre-show
uses the same platform as acid when c4
Picasso reducing production costs
well nobody helped us our car tester
considers the display again it controls
just about everything but the radios
volume everything looks orderly and tidy
with fewer levers and buttons in the car
but is it really a good idea to have a
touchscreen controlling the heater what
if it breaks down and you can't control
the temperature in the car Cujo offers
five different engines for the 3083
gasoline powered and two Diesel's the
one we tested the 85 kilowatt diesel
features a stop-start system which comes
as standard the manufacturer says fuel
consumption is 3.8 liters per 100
kilometers the thrifty French car sells
for twenty four thousand six hundred
euros in Germany amatis has nothing in
principle against dynamic cruise control
but with this one at the car in front of
you suddenly breaks the system goes into
pause mode and tells the driver to
resume manual control mutters ass then
what is the point of a dynamic cruise
control system obstinately a temple mod
aura so what is montez's overall rating
of this car of the year
dead puzzle he says the pujol 308 is a
good car but there is room for
improvement here and there so wouldn't
have been his pick for car of the year
missed some cough the yoga dead
ople presents a racecar for the road the
Astra OPC extreme when it's stripped
down and lightweight construction it's
100 kilograms lighter than the standard
version the roof and rims are carbon
fiber and the back seat was eliminated
under the hood it packs a two-liter
turbo with over two hundred 20 kilowatts
but we'll have to hold our horses opel
hasn't announced a date yet for series
production swiss tuning specialist
rinspeed also designs innovative concept
cars their latest venture is the
exchange based on the Tesla Model S it
shows what the cockpit of a self-driving
car might look like someday it turns out
that might feature swiveling recliners a
steering wheel that slides out of the
way when it's not needed and many other
high comfort enhancements now that's a
vision of the future
up to now Snow country was not exactly
home territory for Mercedes compact
class but that set the change now the
Stuttgart manufacturer is offering some
compact models in all-wheel drive
including the sporty CLA sedan and the
eight and B Class Mercedes originally
developed the 4matic all-wheel drive for
the GLA compact SUV durgavati mercedes
engineer would eager would says they
developed an especially light all-wheel
drive or the compact models it features
an electro hydraulic clutch that
provides variable torque distribution
between the front and rear axles the
computer controlled system can detect
slippage or a difference in rotational
speed between the two axles when that
happens it automatically transfers power
to the rear and that means more
stability and traction sounds great but
what's it like in snowy conditions to
find out we'll team up with driving
instructor Violeta bike up on a testing
ground
violetta guides the a class with ease
even under snowy conditions
yah Monsieur ménard listen the electus
says it's difficult to rain the snow is
packed and the roadway is rutted and
bumpy conventional car with front-wheel
drive or real-wheel drive would have
trouble accelerating or even just
getting started class ID no matter of as
a fondant cheese in an a-class compact
that normally has front-wheel drive but
this one has torque on demand and can
deliver power to all four wheels she's
going to accelerate hard from zero and
the rear axle is powered from the
beginning with 4matic all-wheel drive
the car accelerates like a dream now
she's driving with the electronic
stability program or ESP in her next
test drive shall shut it off to see how
the car drives without it Jen Cotter
buzzer speed you letter explains that
shutting off the ESP can be a good idea
under difficult conditions like in deep
snow so it's worth seeing what happens
now she's driving without the ESP system
next she tests the handling by stepping
on the gas she does have to countersteer
but the car is still under control and
very responsive with even more speed
she's still counter steering but even
through the turns handling and control
is excellent oh do let's see super
vacation oquilla
here's another comparison on the left
the all wheel a class with ESP on the
right the one without it it's pretty
good but we still recommend sticking
with the electronic stabilizer in most
cases the compact also comes equipped
with a seven-year dual clutch
transmission cardiac spudgy's violetta
says it's a fantastic car for these
conditions if you're on a ski holiday
for example you'll master the terrain
with ease and compared to heavier
vehicles whose weight keeps them solid
in the curves the compact is a lot of
fun to drive documenting compact inside
so go Domingo frosh boss we tested the
a-class as an a 250 4matic it puts out a
nice 155 kilowatts and 350 newton meters
of torque in germany this model retails
for twenty six thousand euros add up
that makes it a bit over 2,000 euros
more than the corresponding front wheel
version the Mercedes engineer says a
driver on a dry city street won't notice
any difference between the front wheel
and all-wheel versions the all-wheel
compact isn't much heavier than the
standard one and the all-wheel drive is
deactivated when it's not needed so fuel
consumption is it all that much higher
than otherwise than kind of glue them if
I walk you to have often mercede says
the all-wheel-drive compact consumes
about half a liter more fuel per 100
kilometers than the regular version for
flat terrain it might not be worth it
but for mountain driving and difficult
terrain it's a clear advantage
the Apollo 3500 GT is a sports car with
southern Flair its lines were inspired
by the iconic cars of its age such as
the Jaguar e-type and in particular the
stunningly beautiful Ferraris designed
by Pininfarina positions is this
enthusiast says the Apollo is a kind of
American Ferrari and very rare
the Apollo 3500 GT was intended to
provide an alternative to European
sports cars which were often very costly
to maintain this American Ferrari was
also powered by an American engine of v8
it's three and a half liters of cubic
capacity produced a sporty sound and
more than enough propulsion for the
lightweight Apollo which weighed just a
thousand kilos and fourth gear the 200
horsepower GT could hit a top speed of
210 kilometers an hour a pretty
respectable pace back in the early 1960s
the Silvan at leas glob says the goal
was to create America's answer to the
Ferrari using American technology in an
Italian body mikasa technical detail in
shock oh sorry for the engine they chose
a newly developed v8 from GM's Buick
motor division the three and a half
liter all aluminum engine was very light
perfect for a sports car this engine
went on to enjoy great success as the
rover v8 in various models including the
Range Rover the morgan plus 8 and the
TVR 350 I
in spite of its mass produced American
technology the Apollo can go like the
wind the engine sits far behind the rear
axle and ensures even weight
distribution no front heavy American
Cruiser the Apollo is an agile and
speedy Gran Turismo that's fun to drive
the Apollo's contours are inspired by
Italian design though it's anything but
a Ferrari ripoff it's design is unique
even if it does a dump many details used
in Ferrari models in the 1960s but
that's little wonder
because they wouldn't and today his
graph explains that the body was made in
italy and the designer was Italian
Franco scaglione had worked for Ferrari
and bad Tony before the car bodies were
shipped to the US but the COS got away
out of hand compatible so just 70 odd
Apollo's were produced over the course
of six years 40 are thought to be still
in existence today auglaize gough spent
years looking for his apollo during this
time he became somewhat of a specialist
on the sports car and advises apollo
fans and owners around the globe
the technical session off says the cars
technology is affordable he says all the
parts are available as long as you know
what car they came from he says that the
tough but special thing is the body
which was handmade by intima conniekins
the first two cars were made of aluminum
but then they realized that cost too
much after that the cars were made from
steel with aluminum hoods trunk lids and
doors he says it's an American Ferrari
and very rare physicians asst it's a
sign Amelie Concha form one exclaims i
dinna tune with the help of experts in
five years of hard work Gough completely
rebuilt his Apollo he now owns a second
Apollo a 5000 GT with the larger engine
that was installed later it's another
restoration project finding the right
internal parts hasn't been a problem the
replacing missing or damaged parts of
the body work is far from easy handwork
and improvisation are the order of the
day wasn't even funny crowd says that in
such a case you must make everything
yourself he needed a rocker panel as
they're very prone to rust in these cars
so he had to produce one from scratch
himself at the front here he had to
install a part two which he made himself
because no replacements exist comets
like the Ferraris of its day the
Apollo's body was completely handmade
the traces of this are still visible in
the sheet metal today
Munson often homograph says you can
still see the hammer blows on the
bodywork and that even when you're
restoring it you can't be too exacting
you can really see the difference
compared with factory produced or
machine made bodies but he says that's
how things were at that time he points
out a spot where you can see how the
parts were put together and notes this
is a thing of the past that's hot my hot
water richmond out on visor
in the end the Apollo proved too costly
to make and production ended in 1968 but
on glass cloth still enjoys taking his
out for a spin hello the pollo isn't yet
a high-priced collector's item prices
for these rare models have risen
considerably in recent years